right so let's begin first by noting
that projectile motion is a whole new
subset of motion right in fact you could
treat it all like a different topic some
people do they do it different times
from other kinds of applications of
calculus to the physical world right and
with the straight line motion and we
looked at simple harmonic motion which
is a special kind of straight-line
motion right but when you go projectile
things change dramatically here's what I
mean if I gave you a graph of
straight-line motion and it looked like
this something like that it's the
parabola okay simple kind of thief how
would you interpret that how would you
describe the motion it's pretty simple
remember this is straight line motion
right so what are the axes you've got
you've got displacement and time right
so displacement time well okay no
seriously how would you describe the
motion let's call the displacement off
down if that's okay right we start the
origin okay and then we start moving
upward away from the origin and then we
turn around and then we come back right
the important thing is that this is this
is time going here right it's not
actually moving you're not any
horizontal way okay but you see we're
going to projectile motion if you get
exactly the same diagram right you have
a drastically different situation right
because the axes are totally different
you've got your actual second dimension
over here right so now X goes back where
he belongs on the horizontal axis right
all that time you spent getting used to
X being vertical well now we're gonna
put it back in the horizontal right
because this projectile motion is true
two-dimensional motion okay we've got
up-down and we've got that right or back
and forth okay so this is vitally
important that you get the distinction
and you know all those times in ur8 we
like do we really have to label the axes
they always mean the same things no they
don't
no they don't and confusing them is a
bad idea right now what we're gonna do
is I assigned an exercise yesterday and
I'm gonna walk through all the simple
questions they've got many many parts
and the ideas they're trying to hold
your hand through the steps and develop
equations
it's a gentle introduction okay so I'm
not sure if you looked at this question
yesterday or if you were looking at
previous exercise in that's five here's
a picture of Steve tosses an apple to
add yes Steve yeah Steve he's he's my
point of origin okay and he throws an
apple okay Adam Steve in an upward I
think that's a coincidence
anyway there we go there's our picture
Adam catches the Apple at exactly the
same height the Steve released it right
so that's why I've got Adam on the axis
here okay but you might notice there are
situations where this is not always the
case
right for instance Steve might be up on
a cliff and he throws it and lands down
on the valley floor something like that
or vice-versa huh Steve might be at the
bottom of the flight of stairs or
something like that and he throws it so
so what else use a high up okay and we
get these kinds of pictures all the time
but this is a nice simple one to be
giving you okay suppose that the initial
speed of the Apple is V equals now I'm
gonna get a new color here and if you've
got one is what it'll help you Joe your
tangent there at the origin which
represents the initial vector right
where it's been thrown up you've got an
initial velocity of 5 meters a second
okay
by the way I know you had the language
of vectors and scalars introduced to you
before all the vector means is that
you've got two parts to where this is
going right an upward direction at a
horizontal direction or as you'll see
later on I'm an angle and magnitude
okay so there's initial velocity five
meters a second and the initial angle of
elevation by the way this language is
very important you need to pay careful
attention to the language the initial
angle elevation alpha which is in here
is given by tan alpha equals two
he'll turn alpha equals two I've already
drawn this diagram because I knew in
advance what this would be but you
should do yourself a favor get your
calculator out and do tan inverse of two
so you have a ballpark of what this
angle is actually equal to it's about
sixty three threes
that's why I've drawn it in that sort of
scale okay obviously don't have to but
it helps to get the picture as accurate
as you can okay
there's a set up so now what do we have
to do right Part A use a Reza Bowl City
resolution diagram to find the initial
values of x dot and y dot okay the lost
city resolution not at me slowly
if this phrase were introduced to you on
Tuesday yeah okay good now let me try
and make sure you all know exactly what
velocity resolution is about right if
you wanted to describe what do you see
if you wanted to describe a point in
space okay and so easiest if we think in
terms of circles suppose this was the
unit circle the unit circle okay if I
want to describe a point of this I could
do it in two ways I could provide a
Cartesian coordinates right I might say
something like okay where might this be
it's the unit circle that might be
something like 0.3 0.9 there you go an X
and a y-coordinate and there's two
numbers in two-dimensional space they
what's the word exhaustively define
where the point is there's nowhere else
that 0.3 0.9 could be I know where I am
okay but that's not the only way to
describe a point on the unit circle
right because we know a couple of ways
to say this we know number one a
parametric definition for this you can
introduce a third quantity a parameter
that defines where you are if I have
function at this point up here right the
parameter that we tend to choose is an
angle right choose an angle one measured
from by a convention the positive side
of the X
and we say look if you know the angle
and I told you it was the unit circle
and you know the radius that also
uniquely exhaustively defines that point
okay I mean if this theater was I don't
know to say for instance 63 degrees okay
and that radius is one there's no other
point where you could be right so you've
got a Cartesian definition and if you
want to call this way either parametric
or jolla definition right so you either
have an x and y or you have an angle and
a magnitude now what we've got here is
an angle and a magnitude okay and
velocity resolution is we are going from
here to here getting a Cartesian
definition if you like okay
so let's draw the diagram shall we
you've seen this rectangle before right
and we're going to draw in the initial
vector there right so here it goes it's
going upward like sir okay so I'm gonna
put my initial velocity which is five
okay
and the other piece of information that
I need is my angle okay now it's in here
alpha it's probably speaking it's the
tenuous a tube right so I'm gonna bring
that in in a second okay
now which my to resolve velocities what
we're really after is well what are we
after
do you remember to resolve the velocity
what two quantities do I want on this
diagram I want I want X dot which is
where it's down here isn't it there's
the X dot like there's a horizontal
momentum right and I want Y dot which is
up here right okay so really what I'm
doing is Pythagoras yeah can you see
what's happening I'm translating from a
polar definition of where I'm going
right to a Cartesian definition see X's
and Y's right just like these guys right
okay so how would I do it how would you
set it out I think probably the place I
would sign is here I would say 10 alpha
equals 2 well in this diagram 10 alpha
is opposite on adjacent wide on a next
time right
that ratio that's - okay so therefore I
can say whatever X dot is why don't we
double that and now that I have
excellent why not in terms of each other
I can appeal to Pythagoras right and
that's the way that I would say that I
would say but here X dot squared plus y
dot squared equals 5 squared
Pythagoras okay I know what Y dot is
it's 2x start so when I square it I
shouldn't get X dot squared here and for
X dot squared there okay please be
careful for that you're like yes sir
you've got your head so much about
projectiles all that kind of thing that
you forget numbers that Square but leave
me seen hundreds of times okay so watch
out we can simplify over here right I've
got five x dots Squared's here between
my there right so I get X dot squared
bu5 yeah and so at this point I'm going
to say X is equal to the square root of
five and you can say well because X dot
has to be positive okay
later on sometimes we will look at
situations where for instance Steve and
Apple and Adam for apples at each other
so you will get negative x dots but
we've had to find for us in this
situation this kind of corner system so
I can say that one value only if X dot
cool now what I was resolving velocity
right what I asked you now I want the
other quantity here I've got this one
that's square root of five right so I
want to get this guy and you can see
from this line here
why don't we cheery five okay okay
suppose I really should supply units on
there as well meters per second
okay so there you go and I'll slap those
both on my diagram done cool velocity
resolved a transition from a pole the
division to a Cartesian one if you want
to think about in those terms